as a woman I feel safe when men are acknowledging their mistakes
not when they're minimizing them
your story is so unique
but it's also an experience that a lot of men can relate to
where you were victim and you were perpetrator
I mean we all under patriarchy
that's pretty much the deal for men right
you're hurt by patriarchy
you're hurt by men who exploit your weaknesses or your vulnerability
then you're taught to not have any vulnerability
and so then you end up taking it out in your romantic relationship
do you feel that dichotomy
you know of being victim and
and perpetrator
is that hard to fathom
and then how do you approach that as a man in our society
yeah I think that that's comes back to
seeing seeing myself act in certain ways and
and make choices that um
I feel are so out of character for myself and not who I wanna be
and not who I wanna be in the future
you you can't minimize
um who you've hurt and
and the actions you've taken
you I have to take accountability for
for the choices that I've made and make amends as well
I just know that when I make those choices
that's not who I am
I wanna find out what it is and how I can change